douglas i want to take you back to
portland again because i know you've
been there
i've i'm puzzled i mean normally riots
peter out in the end that's been the
experience of riots in the united
kingdom
or in europe and even in america until
now but important it seems to be
never ending they seem to be going on
almost if not riots
unrest going on every night and
and yet the mayor of the governor of
oregon they don't
seem to do much about it how i mean have
they just given up on part of the city
uh why is there no political penalty uh
for this because in this in this country
there will be a huge political penalty
to pay yes
that's that's one of the striking things
about uh i'd say not just portland but
seattle
but portland's the sort of ground zero
on this one and
here's the thing i mean you can see you
can see the troubles in a
city like new york at the moment the
same troubles we've got in all of our
cities in london everywhere else
businesses have gone out of business
boarded up shops and much more but you
can't help
thinking in a city like new york well
it's been through ups and downs before
and it'll come back you know the even
with the uh even when there's
lawlessness in new york there was a
little bit the other night
that new yorkers won't put up with this
and they'll vote in at some point
soon a mayor who's for law and order and
a bit more and a bit stronger on all
that and stronger and backing the police
and
tougher measures and much more the thing
with portland is that such an
outlier is that there's a there's
actually
a memorial election coming up the mayor
who's been totally ineffectual
and actually just last month had to move
out of his own apartment block because
antifa were rioting outside it and he
he fled his own home and still won't do
anything about it
he's got one contender against him for
the mayoralty
who's a woman who is an open supporter
of antifa
so here that's the problem for
portlanders
is that they've got a man who's
ineffectual and a woman who supports the
paramilitary groups
and and uh you know this is a as you say
andrew this is a very
unusual situation in a democracy as for
where the momentum comes from it comes
back to a couple of things that people
have already mentioned
one is um people whipped up into i think
hysterical and catastrophic ideas about
the nature of the society they're in
uh another is simply that in the wake of
the lockdowns and much more
this is something for a certain type of
person to do
they get meaning they get a sense of
purpose
they honestly think that if they pull
down enough things and there's not much
left in portland to pull down
by my own observation but if they pull
down enough things
they'll kind of get to this fair
equitable society that they dream of i
mean there's no such thing of course
they're just going to continue to
immigrate their city and chase more and
more people out of it
but it is this lack of willingness on
the part of the governor
and of the mayor to for instance
and the d.a i should add by the way
that's the most shocking thing for a
british viewer
that that an elected d.a a highly
political
figure decides not to prosecute
serious crimes carried out by rioters
is why they get into this situation you
can go and smash a lot of stuff up
including smashing
people up in in in oregon and nothing
happens
to you and that's why it's still going
on
are plain folk in uh portland voting
with their feet
just getting out yes uh it's uh
it's just i i can't stress enough i
tried in the magazine last week in my
report from portland to stress this but
you know
i think a lot of people even in america
but especially outside america
would be genuinely shocked by the state
of this city
and there are other cities in a similar
situation seattle the area formerly
known as chas
is just boarded up shop after boarded up
shop
and a tent city sitting in the middle of
what used to be one of the attractive
parks of the place
the homelessness problem by the way
that's the same in l.a
there are these massive problems uh uh
which
frankly whoever wins the election uh
for the white house has to find some way
to address
it seems to me as an outsider utterly
shocking
that you can have an area like downtown
portland which has been entirely handed
over to the homeless
where every single municipal building
like all others is
covered in in smashed windows boarded up
windows
graffiti no business is going to come
back to this place
and it's it's a real disgrace to america
of course
if i can just say so the reason also
it's
it's been in some way left to rot like
this
is and i i do stress that of course the
president did try to send in federal
guards earlier in the year to deal with
this
but to some extent the reason why
portland has taken on the significance
it
it has is because it looks like a sort
of exemplar of what happens
when you defund the police and uh
and pull back law enforcement and do all
of the things that the radical parts of
the left want to do
it's become something like a sort of
lesson to the rest of the country
it's terrible for the poor people who
live in portland because there are many
decent people who just want to live in a
safe city
which isn't immiserated like this but to
some extent it has
understandably become something like a
lesson
to the rest of the country you know if
if you go that way
this is what it looks like douglas we we
often
we're often told that america the bombs
like a tinder box a dry
tinderbox we see the sort of endless
unrest in cities like portland or
seattle
seems to go on forever which was not
true of the riots in 68
for example we've had this new outbreak
in philadelphia we see amazing pictures
of
americans trump supporters also biden
supporters or black lives matter
supporters
walking around looking like paramilitary
groups armed with semi-automatic
rifles you wouldn't see that in any
other democracy anywhere
in the world um if it is a contested
election how dangerous
is it or how likely is it that that will
manifest itself on unrest in the streets
this is an absolutely crucial question
which i think is on so many american
voters minds at the moment
the number of people in different states
who've told me for instance
that they're going to vote on the day or
vote in advance and then get out of the
city
is really quite alarming and in multiple
cities i've been told that
the places you mentioned portland oregon
seattle i've been to in
recent weeks and yes i mean they've had
nightly rioting
and protests for months on end now and
this is definitely a driver to a
part of the trump base he's very uh
adept at saying to people he famously
with his suburbs comments the other week
which he's reiterated a number of times
he's very adept at saying to people look
you know it's it's
law and order and your home being
protected or
it's the kind of chaos you see in
portland
the thing that struck me in recent weeks
is that some some people have been
asking you know
if uh if if biden wins uh
are there protests and rights and i i
can't see a scenario really seriously
where there are
if biden wins certainly if he wins very
clearly
i think it's a pretty smooth uh
transition
i think that if if trump wins very
clearly
i think there are definitely going to be
cities in this country by the way
they're already advertising for it
antifa blm
have already advertised that their act
they're going to do an activity
on the night of the election in portland
and in seattle
other places will be joining in i think
that if trump wins we'll see that now
here's
here's the worst case scenario though
the worst case scenario
is if it appears on the day that biden
has won
and then from late counts and much more
it turns out to be trump i honestly
think in this city and we're not just
talking about outright places like
uh uh uh portland here but in major
cities like the one i'm sitting in at
the moment
new york i think we're going to see
serious unrest
uh i i can't stress the extent to which
outsiders
haven't appreciated this i hadn't quite
appreciated until this trip
the organizational impetus behind these
groups
is really considerable they have their
own effectively policing units
they have their own blockading units
just cut off streets
when the police step back they step in
as sort of paramilitary organizations
and run the streets that they're in
and that's aside from just things like
the outbreak
of looting and things that we saw the
other night
i think this country is at the risk of
being in real
trouble in the coming days
you